[Music]  the latest on Brad Pitt and Angelina  Jolie's divorce battle a source tells ET  that Brad is happy and relieved that the  custody dispute has died down in the  media yes good as for the divorce that's  still in the process of being resolved  but according to our source the pair  have been speaking directly and making  progress quote privately and properly  our source also says brad has been  spending time with the kids in LA and  continues to be united with Angelina and  that they are doing what's in the best  interest of the children and in response  to this moment with Angelina on Good  Morning America last month in the past  he described Brad often as a wonderful  father of course is part of the family  do you still believe that of course of  course we will always be a family boys  our source tells Edie Brad knows  Angelina is a really good mom  [Music]  you